[Musique]
je suis revenu en polynésie en 2015 dans
l'espoir de faire du cinéma
je pense qu'on peut être à la fois femme
à la fois polynésienne est à la fois
signé je crois surtout qu'il ya des
histoires polynésienne qui mérite d'être
racontée
il ya des histoires fillon pour héroïne
principale des femmes en 2008 j'avais
réalisé un court métrage de fiction
s'appelait est allié aux états unis donc
j'étais alors en école de cinéma en
australie ou victorine khaled georgia et
pour mon film de fan sic en fait on est
revenu à tahiti pour tourner ce court
métrage avec une quinzaine de
techniciens locaux et quatre étudiants
australiens donc ce film c'était
l'histoire d'une petite fille qui veut à
tout prix devenir a lieu et elle y
parvient elle va rentrer dans le plan
des agneaux sauf qu'elle n'aura pas le
droit d'avoir d'enfant donc ce film
parle de cet attachement à cet enfant
est le fait de ne pas pouvoir le garder
ce film donc je vous en ai tiré un
extrait donc ils datent de 2008 et je
vais où le mettre
[Musique]
et nous à nouveau à nous à noté avec lui
l'oit et hameaux et
[Musique]
eolo et à you mind ayoman à yahoo il
autorités à aller pour les poules non on
est homo à toi mon état pour notre
organe à noah twitter et autres
[Musique]
et orientaux demo à lyon et face aux
noix été mal ou des mollets ou y qui
donc voilà donc là c'était deux minutes
extrait les 15 minutes de film merci
donc ce court métrage de fiction il a
beaucoup voyagé il l'a été en sélection
dans une quinzaine de festivals dans le
monde et il est allé à palm springs
il est allé à montréal il est allé à
biarritz il est allé en afrique du sud
il est allé en nouvelle-zélande dont pas
mal de dom tom et il a été primé en
irlande et en australie
donc en fait ce film il a beaucoup plus
voyager que moi et donc ce film que
j'avais fait en 2008 je suis en train de
le développer en long métrage de fiction
donc pour l'année prochaine en 2018
donc c'est ce sera dix ans après le
court métrage l'histoire dans la version
longue de et à rio il va dîner c'est
l'entremêlement de deux histoires de
femmes l'une dans le passé dans une
société polynésienne précontact donc
cette fameuse a lieu que vous avez lu et
l'autre dans une société moderne à la
pointe de la technologie ce qui
m'intéresse en fait dans ce film c'est
de comprendre l'évolution de la place de
la femme dans le monde et voir si les
choses en réellement évoluer ou si elle
stagne et aussi ce qui m'intéresse dans
ce sujet c'est de comprendre la relation
que l'on peut avoir avec la matin la
maternité en tant que femme je voulais
aussi rappelé que les adieux en ont
vraiment existé
c'était des artistes itinérants qui
allaient d'îles en îles qui vénérait le
dieu oraux et est en fait il dédié toute
leur vie à la il faisait que ça donc le
film le la version longue de yali
ivanine et j'aimerais que ce soit un
mélange des genres donc il ya deux
histoires en panne en parallèle
et les deux histoires en fait se font
écho j'aime beaucoup mélanger les genres
dans les films que je fais j'essaye
toujours dans les réalisations que je
fais j'essaye de d'allier tradition et
modernité enracinement et ouverture sur
le monde parce que je pense que c'est ce
mélange là qui il va faire partie de
notre évolution en fait je crois
profondément que on a besoin de
s'appuyer sur nos racines pour se
tourner vers l'avenir et pour
appréhender au mieux le monde qui
s'offre à nous il ya un proverbe hawaïen
qui m'a beaucoup touché et qui dit
hikawa ma mois
ik ouamar op qui signifie en fait que
d'un avenir réside dans temps passer en
fait ce que cette phrase sous-entend
c'est que temps passé peut être riche de
connaissances de savoirs faire et de
sagesse et que si tu te laisse guider
par compass et il va t'amener vers des
perspectives et des actions pour le
futur qui seront bonnes ce contraste
entre racines et feuilles ou
enracinement et ouverture sur le monde
ça a été un tiraillement qui qui a
toujours été en moi je pense depuis tout
petit je pense que c'est peut-être du
fait de notre insularité
le fait que ce soit si petit ici quand
on a toujours envie de regarder ce qui
se passe alex à l'extérieur et donc moi
j'ai toujours été tiraillé entre
l'extérieur et l'ici et l'ailleurs il
ici il ya un proverbe mélanésiens qui
m'a suivi pendant quelques années que
j'aime beaucoup donc je vais vous le
lien tout homme est tiraillé entre deux
besoins le besoin de la pirogue c'est à
dire du voyage de l'arrachement à
soi-même et le besoin de l'arbre c'est à
dire de l'enracinement de l'identité et
les hommes errent constamment entre ces
deux besoin en s'aidant tantôt à l'un
tantôt à l'autre jusqu'au jour où ils
comprennent que c'est avec l'arbre qu'on
fabrique la pirogue donc ce tiraillement
gelé subi on va dire et je suis parti à
l'étranger et ensuite j'ai compris en
fait ce mythe
du coup je me suis dit bon j'ai vu
l'étranger j'ai vu comment c'était je
vais prendre le meilleur de là bas je
vais rentrer chez moi je vais retrouver
mes racines et du coup ça a donné
les productions audiovisuelles que je
réalise maintenant donc je suis revenu
en polynésie il s'était écoulé une
dizaine d'année 1 et en revenant ici je
me suis aperçu que les audiovisuel
c'était bien développé ça a été une
belle surprise
c'est toujours bien de voir qu'il ya pas
mal de productions étrangères qui
viennent tourner ici il ya pas mal de
productions locales aussi dispo ici
est ce que j'aime par dessus tout c'est
voir que on est de plus en plus sensible
en fait au film sur l'identité sur notre
identité
par contre il ya quelque chose qui me
chagrine un peu quand je regarde les
films d'aujourd'hui en règle générale
c'est que la voix des femmes est très
peu représentée je sais pas si vous vous
en apercevez en allant au cinéma sur
internet ou à la télévision
il ya très peu de films qui sont
réalisés par des femmes je me souviens
que quand j'étais encore en école de
cinéma
donc je faisais une licence de
réalisation donc c'est un cursus de
trois ans on n'était que deux filles en
dans ma classe 2 sur 14 mon cdd des
classes réduites mais si on fait on
prend ce ratio là ça fait moins de 15%
de deux femmes
voilà en gros qu'ils vont devenir ils
vont devenir réalisatrice je regardais
les autres promotions à l'école où
j'étais il y avait les premières années
les deuxièmes années les 3e année et
c'était le même ratio à chaque fois très
très peu de femmes dans ce milieu et
donc je crois vraiment que que ce
domaine est un domaine très masculin en
fait
ensuite après mes études en australie
je suis parti à paris pour exercer mon
métier ça a été très difficile à paris
ça a été très difficile en france de
réaliser en fait de passer à la
réalisation
parce que c'est très un milieu très
fermé surtout dans le milieu du cinéma
et là je me suis aperçu en fait au fil
des rencontres et puis aussi en lisant
les statistiques que il y avait qu un
film sur cinq en france qui est réalisé
par une femme
donc que 20% des films qui sont réalisés
par des femmes en france la france faut
savoir que c'est parmi les dix plus
grands producteurs de films et
exportateur de films au monde donc je me
suis demandé est-ce que ça veut dire que
ce milieu en fait ne suscite pas du tout
l'intérêt des femmes parce que les
femmes n'ont pas de vocation pour ces
métiers là sur tous les métiers
techniques dans l'audiovisuel et et il y
avait un autre constat encore plus
affligeant c'est que à paris en france
quand on est une femme et qu'on est
réalisatrice on est payé 40 % moins
qu'un homme
à diplôme égaux à compétences égales on
ait toujours payé presque moitié moins
du coup le cnc donc le centre national
du cinéma a sorti un rapport en 2015 il
faisait l'état des lieux un peu des
productions qu'ils avaient aidé en
france et donc en france en 2015
il ya eu 300 films à peu près qui ont
été aidés par le cnc donc sur ces 300
films il ya soixante cinq films qui ont
été réalisés par des femmes
232 par des hommes est juste de cinq
productions qui était déco réalisation
mix entre un homme et une femme
ensuite après la france je me suis dit
je me demande si aux etats-unis c'est
pareil parce que quand on sait que les
états unis c'est la mecque du cinéma et
que et quand même eux qui régissent le
le manque de l'audiovisuel et du cinéma
avec toutes les influences américaines
qu'on reçoit à la télé ou cinéma
eh ben aux etats unis c'est encore pire
aux états unis il ya seulement sept pour
cent de femmes y réalise et en film et
en télévision il ya seulement 17% qui
sont des femmes dans les équipes
techniques donc 17% de technicienne du
coup ça ça soulève pas mal de questions
je trouve de regarder ça parce que les
états unis n'est pas le plus gros
producteur de films au monde
ils ont été détrônés depuis très très
longtemps par l'inde et maintenant ils
viennent d'être détrôné par le nigeria
et la chine
mais les états unis quand même continuer
à abreuver les médias
tous les moyens de communication avec
leur film donc je me suis dis donc ya
pas de vocations chez les femmes
s'il y a aussi peu de femmes qui
l'étudient qui veulent faire de l'art et
de la réalisation et à aussi peu de
technicienne femmes et en fait quand on
de retour en france je me suis aperçu
que on avait des stages et en relais pas
mal de stagiaires dans les sociétés prod
dans lesquels j'ai travaillé et elle me
disait qu en fait à l'école elle était
il y avait autant de femmes que d'hommes
en réalisations en france en 2010 est
sauf que si on regarde les chiffres du
cnc mais y'en a que 20 % qui vont faire
des films
non seulement les films ne sont pas
faits par des femmes mais en plus les
films donnent une mauvaise
représentation de la femme 1 c'est mon
avis mais c'est ce que j'observe
habituellement quand je regarde un film
il ya très peu de place qui est laissée
à la femme dans les films elles ont
souvent un second rôle elles ont souvent
des rôles secondaires et le cinéma
persiste à nous donner une image biaisée
de la femme entre la femme objet la
femme fatale la femme écervelée la
blonde de service quoi la belle plante
le glamour la femme soumise la femme au
foyer la femme maternelle la femme
garante de la descente banques etc etc
c'est tellement stéréotypé et plein de
clichés les rôles féminins maintenant
dans l'audiovisuel que des fois ça me
fait peur quoi surtout quand on pense
que l'industrie du film se veut être le
reflet de la société moderne
ça soulève vraiment des questions est ce
que ça veut dire si je prends ce que je
viens de vous dire avant est ce que ça
veut dire que notre société moderne elle
et sexistes et machistes
eh ben je prends je crois bien que oui
franchement en toute honnêteté je pense
que la société moderne actuelle est
profondément machiste et sexy et c'est
pas que le cas dans l'audiovisuel pas
touche pas mal de secteurs d'activité il
ya juste à regarder autour de vous
combien de femmes sont dirigeante de
pays ont bien deux femmes son chef
d'entreprise combien de femmes
travaillent dans le milieu médical qu'on
ya deux ans de travail dans le monde
scientifique
combien de femmes travaille dans
l'informatique ou l'aéronautique ou dans
l'armée et en audiovisuel en france en
reste 20 % ici je pense que c'est à peu
près pareil on est aussi touchée vous
prenez le dixit vous l'ouvrez vous
regardez les 200 plus grandes
entreprises de polynésienne et je vous
garantis qu'on est bien loin de la
parité
personnellement moi même vision de la
femme elle est vraiment loin de tous les
clichés que le cinéma veut nous imposer
parce que pour moi la femme c'est
surtout les femmes que je rencontre dans
mon entourage ou au quotidien je trouve
que c'est des femmes fortes des femmes
attachante des femmes qui ont des
faiblesses qui ont des problèmes oui les
femmes névrosé il y en a des maniaques y
en a il ya un peu de tout en fait c'est
les femmes en fait ça plusieurs facettes
et on devrait pas rester catalogué dans
don de la soumission ou autre je pense
que la femme d'aujourd'hui elle est
indépendante elle est libérée et surtout
elle et endurante
lorsqu'une femme si vous l'observez
autour de vous un entre vos grands-mères
vos mères vos soeurs vos arrière grand
mère mais elle gère tout elle gère et
leurs carrières et leurs enfants et
leurs hobbies et leur sport et leurs
animaux et les parents et les grands
parents
elle s'occupe de tout elles gèrent leurs
vacances et elle arrive comme ça à
jongler un peu avec avec tout quoi donc
je crois surtout que les femmes sont
attachantes et elles sont fortes et
elles sont loin de l'image stéréotypée
qu'on veut nous en donner
et donc ces femmes c'est comme ça que
j'ai envie de les décrire dans mes films
c'est comme ça que j'ai envie que mes
héroïnes soit je pense qu'une femme un
peu galéré mais elle va toujours se
relever
donc et alleo iban et je le fais surtout
parce que j'ai envie de savoir qui
sommes-nous en tant que femme
aujourd'hui quelle est notre place
quel est notre rôle est ce qu'on a
vraiment évolué dans la société est ce
que notre place a changé nos positions
ont changé
est-ce qu'on a des aspirations profondes
et surtout comment est-ce qu'on voit
notre avenir
je crois très fortement que le cinéma et
les films ont un impact sur le monde
je crois que la télévision l'internet
les films en général peuvent jouer un
rôle et influencer le comportement des
gens j'ai envie de croire que le cinéma
peut changer le monde c'est peut-être
utopique mais je pense que c'est
possible et je crois surtout que le
cinéma il peut changer le monde mais de
manière positive
sauf que cette évolution positive
elle passera que si les gens font des
programmes et y passe des messages
réfléchi et réseaux cette évolution
positive pour moi elle ne passera que si
il ya une multiplicité des regards ou
multiplicité des visions sur le monde
une diversité des genres est donc une
diversité de réalisation je crois
surtout qu'il faut une diversité bain de
réalisateur est aussi de réalisateur
merci beaucoup merci à tous et oser
faire du cinéma
[Applaudissements]